make a statement on misconduct and
vetting in the Metropolitan Police
Service following the horrific David
Carrick case and I thank you for your
statement just there
yesterday was a dark day for British
policing and the Metropolitan Police as
an officer admitted being responsible
for a monstrous campaign of abuse
Mr Speaker I am sure the whole house
will want to join me in expressing my
sympathy to the victims and thank them
for their courage in coming forward
it isn't horrible for them to have
suffered as they have
they were manipulated and isolated and
subjected to horrific abuse
for anyone to have gone through such
torment is harrowing
but for it to have happened at the hands
of someone they entrusted to keep people
safe is almost beyond comprehension
the victims have shown extraordinary
strength and courage their testimonies
were essential in ensuring that Carrick
faces Justice for his crimes it's thanks
to them that this vile Predator has been
taken off our streets and the public are
safer
as a result
Mr Speaker the police perform a unique
and critical function in our society
every day
thousands of decent hard-working police
officers perform their duties with the
utmost professionalism
they feel pride in putting on their
uniform and want only the best for the
communities that they serve
I know that they will share our
Collective disgust that a fellow officer
could be responsible for such a
Despicable betrayal of everything that
they stand for
it's imperative that this cannot happen
again
and so I'm grateful for lady eilish
angelini's assurance that she will look
at this heinous case as part of her
inquiry
Mr Speaker from the moment I became
homosexual I've made clear that things
have to change
public trust is precious
our model of policing by consent connect
cannot cannot work effectively without
it
I discussed this case yesterday with the
commissioner of the Metropolitan Police
Sir Mark Rowley and I'm encouraged by
the action that he has taken so far with
his team to root out officers who are
not fit to wear the badge
this effort is being spearheaded by a
new anti-corruption and abuse command
but there is still some way to go to
ensure that the force can command the
trust of the people that it serves
it is vital that the Metropolitan Police
and other forces double down on their
efforts to root out corrupt officers
this may mean more shocking cases come
to light in the short term
it's a matter of the utmost importance
that there are robust processes in place
to stop the wrong people joining the
police in the first place
which is why the government has invested
in improving recruitment processes and
supporting vetting as part of over three
billion pounds that we have provided for
the police uplift program
I expect this work to continue at PACE
and for all Chief constables to
prioritize delivery of the
recommendations made by the police
inspectorate's recent report on vetting
counter-corruption and misogyny
it's now for the Metropolitan Police to
demonstrate that they have an effective
plan in place to rapidly improve their
vetting processes
much of the impetus for change must come
from within policing but this government
will continue leading from the front
as I've been clear we are bringing
forward part two of the Angelini inquiry
to make recommendations on how forces
can improve culture and tackle the root
causes of police criminality and
misconduct
the inquiry was established by the then
Home Secretary my right honorable friend
the member for Whitton and I pay tribute
to her for her commitment and Leadership
on these critical issues
yeah
as well as ensuring vetting processes
are watertight there must be fair and
effective arrangements for dealing with
those who behave or act in a wholly
unacceptable way while serving
baroness Casey has recently identified
concerns with the misconduct and
dismissals process within the
Metropolitan Police
it takes too long it doesn't command the
confidence of police officers and it's
procedurally burdened bureaucracy and
process appear to have prevailed over
ethics and Common Sense
that's why I've announced an internal
review into police dismissals the
reviews terms of reference are being
published today
Mr Speaker
this case will rightly throw a spotlight
once again on women's safety
no one should suffer abuse or feel
frightened or harassed whether they are
at home out and about or online
we are taking concerted action to
prevent violence against women support
victims and survivors relentlessly
pursue perpetrators and strengthen the
system as a whole
on rape specifically we are focused on
delivering improvements across the board
so that victims get the support they
deserve and cases are pursued rigorously
from report to court
there have been some important steps
forward since the publication of the
rape review in 2021 the number of
referrals and charges have increased
nationally while new operating models
for the investigation and prosecution of
rape are being developed through
operation ceteria Mr Speaker
none of us can undo the suffering of
carricks victims
but I can assure the house that this
government will not shy away from
challenging the police to meet the
standards we all expect of them
change must happen and as Home Secretary
I will do everything in my power to
ensure that it does
I commend this statement to the house
shuttle Home Secretary Yvette Cooper
thank you Mr Speaker this is a truly
shocking and appalling case and I
welcome the statement today a serving
police officer
admitting to some of the most serious
and devastating crimes I joined the Home
Secretary in making giving Tribute to
The Bravery of the victims who have come
forward but we have to face up to the
further evidence that this case has
brought up of appalling failures in the
police vetting and misconduct processes
that are still not being addressed by
the government and are not being
addressed in this statement and I would
say to the Home Secretary that given the
scale of the problems not just in this
case but in previous cases as well her
statement is very weak and it shows a
serious lack of leadership on something
that is so brave and affects confidence
in policing as well as serious crimes
failures
to respond or take seriously allegations
of violence against women by a serving
police officer by others serving police
officers allegations of domestic abuse
not taken seriously in the vetting
processes and in this case a failure to
suspend for example a failure to suspend
David Carrick when rape allegations were
made in July 2021 even though the Met
police knew there had been domestic
abuse allegations two years previously a
misconduct process that concluded there
was no case to answer despite the
repeated alarms being traced a full
vetting check not triggered and David
carrick's permission to carry firearms
restored
and most shocking of all is that this
happened at the height of the alarm
about Wayne cousins and the murder the
deeply disturbing murder of Sarah
everard
and this undermines confidence for women
confidence for victims but also for
police officers who are working so hard
and especially for women police officers
who may themselves have reported
misogynistic abuse and for officers who
are doing excellent work every day to
tackle violence against women and girls
and know that confidence in that work is
being undermined now we support the
commission as the new met Commissioners
determination to take action but this is
not just about the met we have had
concerns about misogyny and culture
raised in Sussex and Hampshire and
Derbyshire and gwent in police Scotland
in other forces
and there has been a lack of leadership
from the government on police standards
for years after the truly appalling
murder of Sarah everard by a serving
police officer home office ministers
promised change the then Home Secretary
promised to set up processes that would
prevent this happening again
that has badly failed
there are still no legal requirements on
vetting forces can effectively do what
they want they don't even have to check
employment history and character
references and some don't they don't
even have to interview people beforehand
and when the inspector came up with
damning conclusions that hundreds if not
thousands of police officers who should
have failed betting including corrupt
and predatory officers who have
committed including officers who have
committed offenses on indecent exposure
and domestic abuse are still in the job
the policing Minister refused to even
make it a requirement for police forces
to follow the recommendations of the
inspectorate they just Shrugged and said
that it was a matter for police forces
to follow there's been no response to
make this compulsory to follow vetting
guidance no requirement to make it
compulsory to follow the reforms and all
we've got in this statement is a
continuation of existing Angelini review
and a new review another one on
dismissals which I welcome because this
had there are concerns that the
dismissals process has become more
difficult and has become worse since
well-intended reforms were introduced
but have not worked as intended so I
work on that review but it was announced
in October and it still hasn't started
and all the Home Secretary has done is
re-announce it today and some of the
things that police forces have been
doing to tackle misogyny or to increase
diversity to improve their response to
communities and to Crime the Home
Secretary has dismissed as woke even
though they are about tackling some of
the most serious crimes and it's about
to how seriously they tackle violence
against women and girls more broadly
where we know that the prosecution rate
the charge rate for rate has dropped to
a shameful 1.5 percent it has dropped by
two-thirds over the last seven years and
again home office ministers promised
that tackling violence against women and
girls would become part of the
compulsory strategic policing
requirement it has been reported that
that has not happened can she confirm
that nine months after ministers
announced it she has not made it a
requirement in the Strategic policing
review to prioritize violence against
women and girls
Mr Speaker after the murder of Sarah
everod by serving officer labor called
for change after the horrific murders of
Bieber Henry and Nicole smallman labor
called for leadership after the shameful
case of child Q labor called for reform
after the shocking Charing Cross station
report labor demanded action after the
Stephen Port inquiry labor called for
reform
and after the case is right across the
country of abuse or of misogyny labor
has demanded change conservative
Minister's promised action would be
taken but they have failed to do so
labor will change the law labor will
overhaul the vettings misconduct and
standard system because it is time to
change and we are letting down police
officers across the country who do
excellent work and who are being let
down by these failures in the system and
most of all women are being let down
too late for all the warm words in the
home secretary's statement what is she
actually going to do to make sure that
standards are raised Home Secretary
thank you Mr Speaker it's a
disappointment that the shadow home
sector has resorted to cheap political
lines I don't think today is a day for
political attacks there's been a human
tragedy at the heart of this case and
ultimately politics should be set aside
I'm willing to work with anybody the
inspectorate the overriding politician
responsible for the Met police a labor
politician siddiq Khan I'm willing to
work with all the chief constables I'm
willing to work with everybody in this
chamber so that we bring about change
and safety and improve standards in our
policing forces around the country and
that's why I support the statement of
the police commissioner the Met
commissioner yesterday where he accepts
that what they were failings there's no
question about that there were failings
in the system when it came to vetting
and checking
there were uh there were failures by uh
the Met police
it's clear that culture and standards in
police need to change and that's why I'm
clear as well that I'm not going to shy
away from challenging Chief constables
all around the country on the standards
that they uphold and instill in their
individual forces police constables and
police leaders have all accepted the
recommendations set out in the
comprehensive report by the inspector
commissioned by this government in
response to the Sarah everard murder to
look into more closely what procedures
have been put in place and how well
they've been working when it comes to
vetting and checking monitoring and
disciplinary processes relating to
policing it was clear that report
identified several
concerns and failings in policing the
bulk of those recommendations were aimed
at Chief constables the College of
policing and the national policing
Council uh that all of those
recommendations have been accepted and
we're closely monitoring the delivery of
those improvements in rigor and
standards when it comes to the entry
processes vetting and uh checking of new
recruits to policing we've also ensured
that lady Angelini will be looking more
closely into culture in policing to root
out so that we can better Implement and
deliver systems which will root out
misogyny uh predatory behavior sexual
assaults or any other offensive uh
behavior that might lead to criminal
activity within policing
but let me be clear I'm very proud of
this government's track record on
supporting women and girls in the
criminal justice system it's this
government that has put into place a
groundbreaking operation ceteria around
the country to improve practices when it
comes to the police investigation of
rape and serious sexual offenses uh the
prosecution phase and the court
resolution phase and we're already
seeing signs of improvement when it
comes to supporting victims of these
heinous crimes for our Criminal Justice
System it's this government that
introduced a raft of new offenses to
better protect women and girls in
society whether that's upskirting our
Landmark Domestic Abuse Act which
expanded the definition and the
protections available to victims of
domestic abuse stalking
a female genital mutilation forced
marriage I'm very proud of that
leadership and that initiative that this
government has demonstrated when it came
to standing up for women and girls but
we won't be complacent there is of
course further we can go and more we can
do I'm Keen to focus on the solutions
and move forward so that we we don't see
repeated incidents and tragedies like
the one we're talking about today
Mr Speaker
um it's a sorry and in fact a tragic
State of Affairs that the house has
convenient to discuss this issue again
today there's no doubt about that it
really is and I think the Home Secretary
will fully recognize that reviews have
been commissioned since 2021 that led to
the Angelini inquiry and it's part two
that obviously this will feature into
them I think the Home Secretary it'd be
welcome if she could explain how that's
going to work and when that would report
but since then we've had not only the
Angelini work we've had the Louise Casey
review as well which is damning and I'm
afraid the inspectorates report was also
damning into a raft of issues which the
right honorable lady the shadow Home
Secretary has mentioned as well security
vetting misogyny culture practices the
whole culture in policing
recommendations are already there and in
fact if I may say so to the Home
Secretary previous policing ministers
and myself put for proper
recommendations for the Strategic
policing requirement there are issues
that could be resolved and actually
people could be to help to account
sooner rather than later through that
requirement can I urge her to consider
particularly of the tragic cases that we
have heard about relating to this
particular Carrick incident and his
victims that we start looking to put
much of this on a statutory foot in if
we don't do that we are going to be here
again and again and again paying tribute
to victims while quite frankly parts of
the law enforcement system continue to
fill the British public and fell victims
well I want to reiterate my thanks and
tribute to my right vulnerable friend
for her leadership when she was in this
role uh leading from the front uh in the
fight to protect women and girls and
uphold their safety lady eilish Angelini
has confirmed that she will consider the
carrot case in her inquiry and as I've
mentioned part two will be brought
forward and we expect it to provide an
examination of The Wider issues of
policing such as culture and vetting and
the safety of women those are topics of
relevance to this appalling case that
we've heard about this week and let me
just confirm that when it comes to the
Strategic policing requirement violence
against women and girls will be included
SMP spokesperson Alison thugas thank you
Mr Speaker and I thank the Home
Secretary for her statement and I also
want to put on record the smp's tributes
to the victims in this case for their
bravery uh in the face of the ongoing
trauma that they have faced the charges
uh that have been brought against uh
David Carrick are incredibly disturbing
49 charges including 40 24 counts of
rape against 12 women over two decades
including the incredibly disturbing
accounts of domestic violence and
coercive control and yet through this
they met have sought to protect their
own which is incredibly disturbing and
led to the former victims commissioner b
or questioning the commitment to culture
change at Scotland Yard it has been
reported that the Merit is checking back
through
1633 cases of alleged sexual offenses
involving officers or involving
1071 officers over the the past decade
can the Home Secretary tell us more
about what retrospective action she
expects from this review because it
should be a a worry to all of us that
these officers are still out there still
in a job and we may still face what
David Carrick reportedly told women when
he flashed his warrant card and told
victims at Europe I'm a police officer
you're safe with me it is a chilling
Prospect so I would ask the Home
Secretary of how she intends to make
sure that that review is Thoroughly
carried out what updates this house can
can expect
has also worked with police Scotland in
improving standards on this and work is
ongoing in Scotland too but I really
would like to ask some secretary how can
women and people with vulnerabilities
have the confidence that if something
happens to them earlier in London that
they met will respond in a proper way
that respects their dignity
Home Secretary
well The Honorable lady asks a series of
very good questions and just to give a
bit more detail about what the Met
commissioner has set out in terms of his
commitment to strengthen the procedures
there's already a strengthening of
vetting of uh of officers and there's an
active review ongoing of historic cases
where there may have been a flag on
their system for domestic uh incidents
there's also a data washing process
which is ongoing to ensure that their
data is being checked against rigorously
managed National databases in a very
very extensive way and of course there's
this is all being led by a new
anti-abuse and Corruption command unit
which is actually instilling a much more
institutional uh higher standard of
vetting and you know managing and
overseeing this very important issue
Tim bull thank you Mr Speaker apparently
Carrick was known as bastard Dave by his
colleagues in just the same way as Wayne
cousins was known as the rapist but
alarm Bells were not wrong so most
worrying is the culture of cover-up and
complacency that has allowed such abuse
to go on on an industrial scale by
certain individuals in this case by 17
years so we were encouraged on the home
first select committee when the new met
commissioner gave his determination when
he appeared before us to root out this
mindset and these uh and these offenders
but can the Home Secretary say
specifically in the queries and the
concerns he raised the difficulty to
sack officers why Professional Standards
are not investigating more of these
cases that it's not suitable to be
putting these officers
accused of serious offenses on light
duties they should be fully suspended
and there should be a duty of care of
whistleblane what urgent action is she
going to take on those issues now to
restore some confidence in the met in
particular and especially by women of
secretary my right on friend raises a
very good point about the disciplinary
process and indeed Sir Mark Rowley
himself has spoken at length not just at
the uh at his committee but more broadly
about the challenges that uh that he has
faced in trying to uh dismiss
um patently uh in inappropriate offices
and he's come up against a heavily
bureaucratic process which isn't working
and that's why today I've launched a
review Into the process of police
officer dismissals I want to ensure that
we have a fair and an effective system
at removing those officers who are
simply not fit to serve others like
committed Dave Diana Johnson thank you
Mr Speaker in this case
which has rightly shocked the nation is
yet another appalling example of
systematic failures within the police
to confront male violence against women
and girls and the sexist culture that
exists within the police again and again
the home Affairs select committee has
heard evidence of how weak or
non-existent vetting and misconduct
processes have allowed violent male
officers to continue harassing and
abusing women and not just in London but
in forces across the country
the Metropolitan Police Commissioner has
as I understand it made specific demands
of the Home Secretary in relation to
changes around the dismissal of officers
so I wondered could the Home Secretary
just update the house as to what she's
going to do about those specific
requests and why do we need a review
when it's quite clear from the
recommendations of the Majesty's of his
Majesty's inspector of constabulary and
the reports that the home Affairs select
committee have produced of what needs to
be done we don't need another review we
just need action secretary
well I think that it's um important that
we do look closely at exactly what's
happening when it comes to the police
misconduct process concerns have been
raised not only by baroness Casey but
also Sir Mark Rowley and I think what I
want to do is ensure that we have a
system that's fit for purpose for
example there's been concerns raised
about the presence of the legally
qualified chairs and those are somehow
applying a quasi-judicial approach to a
system which should be much more akin to
a disciplinary internal human resources
uh disciplinary approach that's been
highlighted so far as not being uh fit
for serving the purpose and achieving
the goal that we all want which is to
empower Chief constables to make
decisions on disciplinary matters and
for those to be sustained
Jackie Doyle price thank you Mr Speaker
well here we are again it feels like
Groundhog Day I'm here questioning uh
one of our ministers and our government
that I support about culture within the
Metropolitan Police Service
what is going to change I listen very
carefully to to the Home Secretary and
she she listed the new offenses that
this government is is it putting on a
statute but with regard to protecting uh
women and and combating male violence
against women and girls but the real
challenge is the culture towards women
that exists within our Police Service
and throughout our criminal justice
system can I just repeat the question
made by my rational my friend the member
for Whitton when are we really going to
fully use statutory power to protect
women from male violence
Home Secretary well I think she raises a
good point about police culture and
that's why we need to ensure that we
have a good analysis of exactly what
that means we've got some important
findings from the inspector and also
from baroness Casey uh which set out and
her findings are interim they're not
final but they do set out serious
concerns about police culture which is
leading to pockets of this unacceptable
Behavior we've already commissioned the
Angelini inquiries we must let those run
their course and on the basis of those
robust findings we'll be able to take
the right action to ensure that this
kind of behavior is rooted out that
these kind of individuals are not
allowed into the police force in the
first place and that we can better
protect the public and install
confidence amongst the public when it
comes to policing
we now come to mother of the house
that and I completely agree with the
very strong questioning which was put by
the shadow Home Secretary and also agree
with what was said by the former Home
Secretary and the the current chair of
the select committee and I got two
questions the first is about timing and
as honorable members have said and as
has been recognized and complained about
by successive Metropolitan Commissioners
what they say is that the regulations
that this house has put in place in
statutory instruments prevent them
sacking officers who they know are unfit
to be in the metropolitan police so that
puts a responsibility on us to change
those regulations can I suggest that she
in consultation with the Metropolitan
Police brings forward draft regulations
and let's consult not in the overall
generality of a review but let's consult
on those specific draft regulations and
we will be a hundred percent behind find
her when she changes the brings to the
house change regulations so that the
Metropolitan Police are able to manage
the force in the way that we all want to
see them manage and the second point is
about the Sir Mark Rowley and the
response to the Carrick situation is
that it is not just about change in the
future but it's about dealing with those
individuals who are currently in senior
and management positions in the Met who
seem to think that it was all right for
Carrick to be given extra
responsibilities to be promoted and
really an examination of the management
suitability of those officers ought to
be examined by the Metropolitan
commissioner and we need a bit of
transparency about that so will she urge
the Metropolitan commissioner who we're
all supporting in his determination for
culture change to do a transparent
publication of what tracking he has gone
through of when Carrick was looked at
and nothing was done because all of
those senior officers have colluded and
well he also looked through at a
horizontal level all of those officers
who were part of banter who were part of
the immediate culture of this officer
who did nothing to report him and
therefore were colluding in the
perpetuation of these atrocious crimes
I want to do what works and that's why
I've taken very seriously what the Met
commissioner has said about the process
relating to police misconduct hearings
and disciplinary processes the
I've been clear that where there is a
role for government we will act but it's
important that we look carefully at the
issue that's why the review that I've
just announced will cover uh issues like
the legally qualified chairs to ensure
that they're they are actually striking
the right balance and the decisions that
they're making are they are making are
the right ones it's important that we
ensure that the um the trends in the use
of misconduct sanctions and the
consistency of decision making in cases
of sexual misconduct and other violence
against women and girls and those
offenses are appropriate those are kind
of things that we need to look at very
carefully when it comes to the
Metropolitan Police uh as I said the Met
commissioner has instituted a new
anti-corruption and abuse command
specifically to look at any other risk
factors and any other issues relating to
this kind of incident an extra 100
officers were drafted in to use covert
tactics to identify those officers who
act in a corrupt or predatory manner
including those who abuse their
positions in the police I'm encouraged
by those early commitments by the Met
commissioner and I think we need to get
behind him so that we can radically
improve the system
very much Mr Deputy speaker
Mr Deputy speaker I think Sir Mark
rowley's statement was pathetic
yesterday a statement of the blindingly
obvious and anybody can say sorry for
what's gone on this is an absolute
Scandal now wish to support what the
mother of the house has just said in no
comment that has been made is there been
any suggestion of accountability for
anybody else within the Metropolitan
Police over many years regarding this
man's conduct his egregious Behavior was
known there were seven or eight
allegations regarding his behavior yet
nothing was done excuse huge after
excuse after excuse we can worry about
the future but there are people within
the Metropolitan Police who enabled this
man to continue being a threat to women
and girls and they should be sacked
it's important to note that David
carrick's initial vetting to join the
Metropolitan Police took place in 2001
and that was prior to the introduction
of national standards on vetting and
prior to the regime which has been in
place since 2017 and that was introduced
to ensure consistency in decision making
my my vulnerable friend rightly
expresses frustration with the situation
and I agree with him it is incredibly uh
frustrating to be here yet again on
another tragedy I would just gently push
back I I have confidence in Sir Mark
Rowley I think that he has joined uh the
leadership of the Met very recently and
he's not hesitated in accepting the
enormity of the problems that the Met
police is currently facing he's
presented a plan as already taking
tangible action to deliver on that plan
he understands uh that there is a pro a
problem with confidence in the Met
police there are challenges and problems
with standards and performance
um he's honest and Frank about those
challenges it's not shying away about
fixing them
could I asked the Home Secretary who
are watching this review the internal
review when will it report and will
could she ensure that previous
Metropolitan Commissioners also give
evidence to that review
well the review will be carried out in a
a comprehensive and extensive way to
command confidence amongst police
officers members of the public and other
stakeholders and I wanted to report
swiftly I am wary of other more reviews
and reports and inquiries we need action
uh I I my impression is that there is a
real problem with the process I need to
identify exactly what needs fixing and
therefore we thereafter we can take
Swift action
okay
Stephanie speaker may I mirror the home
secretary's comments to pay tribute to
the victims of the David Carrick and
also urge other victims to come forward
uh if they've got any concerns about
serving police officers or anybody else
does my wonderful friend agree with me
that it is important to support the
commissioner so Mark Rowley in his quest
to rid the root of the culture in the
metropolitan police and I hear that you
know the the commissioner is now
investigating nearly a thousand police
officers and staff and so we have to
prepare ourselves for further
Revelations similar to Carrick but does
she also agree with me that it's
important that the police and crime
commissioner for London and his deputy
mayor for policing also played their
part and perhaps they have been missing
in action over the last seven years
well I think my honorable friend makes a
very good point ultimately the
politician responsible for the
performance of the Metropolitan Police
is the mayor of London Sadiq Khan and
ultimately he should be held politically
responsible for failings within the Met
greater support greater priority greater
Focus From Him Would Do no harm
thank you Mr Deputy speaker
um my respect also goes out to The Brave
women who have come forward but women
shouldn't need to be brave the system
should protect them and believe them
when they speak out on the 20th of
September 2021 byline news reported that
more than half met officers found guilty
of sexual misconduct kept their jobs
there's a report today that says some
women that report sexual abuse or
misconduct may see one of those officers
they've met cannot guarantee that
they're not uh they're not using their
power to do that what's been exposed in
the Met is structural and institutional
and I wonder if the minister agrees with
that or even understands that and does
the minister agree that Sadiq Khan name
of London was right to sack Cressida
dick and can I just say that the
ministers respoke approach today in the
chamber this slow kind of kicked the can
down the road we'll do another review
only so herbs to inflict more pain on
women and girls and and really the
minister needs to take that on board if
she is to do her job properly and and we
also need to review all of the cases
that these criminal police officers have
presided over because if they're bad
they're bad they're not just bad in one
case they're bad in all case can I just
say um Mr Deputy speaker
in Brent uh the tragic murder of bibber
Henry and Nicole smallman who were
murdered and the police took pictures of
their bodies
um the pain that their mother goes
through and I speak to their mother on a
regular basis every time there's
something like this it just inflicts
more triggering pain on people who have
gone through and the police were slow to
act now the minister can do something
about this the new commissioner Mark
Riley has said that he needs more
support in being able to sack officers
not another review not another review
another report he needs things to change
and as a chair of the London PLP I just
wonder if the secretary of state is
willing to listen to voices from the
London PRP and work with us as well as
the Met commissioner to change the law
and legislation around this yeah
well there are some Fair points raised
there and and what I find very
instructive on this issue will be it on
an interim basis is the report uh an
interim report by baroness Casey which
looked into the Met its uh standards on
vetting and procedures and it and it did
make for very concerning reading it was
a very in-depth uh that she is currently
carrying out a very in-depth inquiry
into this subject and she found that the
met doesn't fully support the local
Professional Standards units to deal
with misconduct effectively so
effectively the structure relating to
individual commands isn't uh working uh
there is a uncertainty about what
constitutes gross misconduct and what
will be done about it there are some
really important lessons to be learned
from baroness Casey's inquiry into the
met so that we can make sure that things
like this don't happen again
Lee Anderson thank you Mr Deputy speaker
David Carrick is now one of the UK's
most prolific ever rapists and it did
this while serving as a police officers
utterly disgusting but does the Home
Secretary agree with me that we should
review sentences Lord have already done
it for people that kill emergency
workers so how about reviewing the
sentencing law so if a serving police
officer commits these horrible crimes we
increase their sentence and does she
also agree with me that the managers
that knew about this should be psyched
immediately
please remember subjudicy that we
shouldn't be talking about sentencing
Home Secretary just answer the points
that you can
well my my honorable friend again you
know voices the frustration and
disappointment that we are all feeling
today that uh seven police officer uh
has been uh you know found responsible
for such heinous and uh appalling uh
crimes an abuse of trust a shattered
public confidence in policing and has
undermined uh the safety of women and
girls uh we are not going to shy away
from doing what is necessary to ensure
that cases like this are not repeated
and that women and girls in particular
can have confidence in policing around
the country just to remind everybody
there are aspects of this that our sub
duties who please stay well away from
anything relating to things that are
still before the courts Wendy
Chamberlain thank you Mr Deputy speaker
I too commend The Bravery of the women
involved in this case but frankly some
of those women would not have required
to have been brave if action had been
taken as a former police officer I am
disgusted and ashamed by what I've heard
but the um Metropolitan commissioner has
um said the 800 of his officers are
under investigation has the Home
Secretary required similar figures from
other police forces what is the impact
on the operational capability of police
officers to do their business and
finally as the mother of the house
rightly pointed out police officers are
not employed they are not subject to
employment law they are appointed and
actually the staff associations within
the Police Service such as the
Federation play a very important role in
disciplinary and conduct so what
engagement is the Home Secretary having
with them
well the inspectorate reported late last
year
into this issue looking at forces all
over the country and looking at their
performance when it comes to vetting and
monitoring of disciplinary matters when
it comes within policing it uh the
inspector made 43 recommendations uh
largely focused at Chief constables
around England and Wales the College of
policing and the mpcc they've all been
accepted they have to be uh there are
deadlines for spring of this year and
then later this year and we're closely
monitoring the implementation delivery
of all of those recommendations
thank you Mr Deputy speaker we're here
reported on the BBC that this monster
David Carrick perpetrated a campaign of
Terror against his girlfriends he put
drugs in the car he restrained her with
police handcuffs he said who would
anyone believe you or me I'm an
important person I guard the Prime
Minister I'm a police officer this
highlights the length to which this
monster would go and also the challenge
for those victims to come forward so as
well as the very welcome measures that
the Home Secretary set out for us today
which all of which I support does she
agree with me that one thing we can do a
positive thing we can do is bring
forward the victim's Bill to strengthen
the support of the criminal justice
system to these women's to provide
better support to beef up the role of
the independent sexual violence advisors
I know it's not her department but will
she work with me and work with her
colleague at the Justice secretary to
see if we can get parliamentary time for
this bill as quickly as possible
my honorable friend is absolutely right
and I pay tribute to her groundbreaking
work when she was in government to
support uh women and girls and their
safety she's absolutely right and that's
why my right on my friend the Lord
chance the Deputy Prime Minister is
committed to introducing the victim's
Bill I'm a particular uh particularly
supportive of increasing the number of
isvers and idvis I think they've made a
huge difference uh to the experience of
victims going through the criminal
justice system they can make the
difference between a victim withdrawing
and a victim persisting and reaching a
conviction so I think yes uh result
putting more resources through and
introducing important legislation is
absolutely vital
Kerry McCarthy thank you Mr Deputy
speaker when the education secretary was
asked on the radio yesterday if the
government could say that women could
trust the police she replied it's very
important that we do trust the police in
other words I think that's a no we
cannot have a situation where women who
would ordinarily be turning to the
police to rescue them from dangerous
situations whether it's out on the
street whether it's domestic violence
whether they're the victim of abuse
feel that the very person that might
they might be seeking help from is
somebody that they can't trust and might
actually violate them as well so I
endorse what everyone has said about we
need to address this culture within the
police force but can the Home Secretary
set out a timetable where she can tell
us what immediate action she will take
to address this so that women who are in
danger feel that they can look to the
police for support
and I'll be the first person to say that
this is obviously a
disappointing frustrating sobering and
chilling day for policing and it is
regrettable uh and uh a shame that this
has happened uh I would also say that
the poorly behaved the uh you know the
the the the criminal uh police officers
do make up a minority and we do have
tens of thousands of very brave
dedicated men and women all over the
country who will be feeling the
equivalent level of Shame and discuss
that we are expressing here today this
is not in their name this is about
changing a system so that we don't so
that we root out poor behavior and so
that everybody can be proud to be
serving in our police force Mary
Robinson
Deputy speaker cases once again
highlighted the the terrible um internal
processes within our police forces and
also the inability of people to speak up
in a culture which which actively works
against them doing so so many police
officers will not raise issues with
fellow police officers because they fear
for their jobs they fear for their
Employments will the bill by rat
honorable friend take this opportunity
to do a root and brunch investigation
into the culture within the police
forces particularly with regards to the
ability to speak up and whistleblowers
to have their voices heard
it's an important point that my
honorable friend raises and that is
exactly what uh part two of the lady
Angelini inquiry will cover police
culture and how it and whether there is
a culture of fear whether people are
scared to speak up and uh call out
unacceptable Behavior we need to
pinpoint it precisely so that we can
then take action to ensure that there is
an open and welcoming and professional
uh environment within which everybody
can Thrive Carol Monahan yeah that's a
good kidney speaker and there are many
similarities here in the experience of
Women Within the police cement place and
women within the Armed Forces both
organizations in which we should have
complete faith but both organizations
which have failed to act in many
occasions where there are situations of
misogyny and there are two big issues
for me here there are the kinds of the
perpetrator himself
but there's also the failure of senior
officers to act and take action when
concerns have been raised now the Home
Secretary has talked about how action's
going to be taken on offenders she said
much less about what's going to happen
with senior officers who are aware of
such behavior and have covered it up
could she say some more about that
please you're here
well I think that looks um that goes to
the point about the structures in place
to closely monitor new recruits and
ensure that people who are newer to
policing get the right training and
support from their senior leaders and
that's why as part of our historic
police uplift program which is going to
result in record numbers of new of
police officers when we are complete in
a few months time a large part of that
resource has gone to increasing the
vetting capacity the recruitment
resource so that proper standards and
quality assurance is injected and really
part of the process of recruiting new
police officers Simon fell you Mr Deputy
speaker we operate on a model of
policing by consent and I'm afraid too
many people especially women and girls
will be looking at this and saying I
don't consent I don't agree to this
model of policing in the country anymore
and this is just the latest example um
of what we've seen in the Met
cases like this setback trust in the
police they make it more difficult for
decent law-abiding officers to do their
jobs and it's shameful that carrick's
case has been allowed to carry on for so
long with information apparently known
to the force and other forces without
being shared without action being taken
on it
so there are clear lessons we can learn
here about data sharing about improving
whistleblowing about suspending officers
without allowing them to operate on
light duties about removing officers who
we are deeply concerned about it's great
that we are having these reviews it's
great we're trying to learn lessons from
them but I think what people want is
concrete action and action quickly can
the Home Secretary please advise when we
will see that
well as I said we um my older friend
raises the right pointer
about action and that's why a recent
review of uh vetting capacity as of uh
recently as October of last year uh
carried out by the uplift program showed
that 36 forces had responded and 25 had
increased their capacity in vetting
units between February and October of
last year I see that as action I see
that as police forces responding to the
call to improve their services improve
their resources and ensure that there
are better processes and better systems
in place to properly vet and rigorously
monitor uh the the behavior of their uh
of their professionals
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and good
afternoon
Mr Speaker as a former detective
inspector and the Metropolitan please
like everyone I am shocked revolved and
horrified here of the horror crimes of
PC Carrick and the failure the
Metropolitan Police and other police
services which allowed these crimes to
go undetected and prosecuted for almost
20 years
Mr Deputy speaker on behalf of the
hundreds of thousands of honest
hard-working and brave serving and
retired police officers everywhere I
offer my sincere apologies to the
victims in these cases whose needs must
be prioritized and given our complete
and unquesting support
will the Home Secretary confirmed to the
house that an investigation realized
immediately as identified in her review
announced today to identify and
prosecute to the full extent of the law
of the most severe disciplinary action
against any police officer or a member
of the police staff passed or present
who failed in their duty to protect the
public in public office by not reporting
or investigating complaints against PC
Carrick on preventing him from being
arrested prosecuted and brought to
Justice before now
here
I can't comment on the individual case
but what baroness Casey's review
concluded on an interim basis late last
year was that it's taking too long to
resolve misconduct cases within policing
officers and staff do not believe that
action will be taken when concerns
around conduct are raised those are just
a sample of some of the very serious
concerns that she identified when it
comes to the process in place for
monitoring and disciplining police
officers for unacceptable Behavior I pay
tribute to honorable Jennifer and
service within the police force but I
know that whatever is needed to be
changed we will do it belly as a deputy
speaker women in Stroud and around the
country have woken up with their trust
and belief in our Police Service badly
shaken yet again and I know from
speaking to local women the issues in
the Met undermine their confidence in
Stroud police and they can see that the
gloucestershire constabulary is working
hard to protect them and they can see
that they're open to change but when we
know that women are routinely not
reporting violence abuse and harassment
in part because of lack of faith in the
police and with each Force doing
something completely different what is
my right honorable friend doing to
ensure that all police forces get their
act together and show the country that
they are speaking to each other and that
we're going to make National change on
this issue a second
my older friend's absolutely right to to
raise the issue about uh the confidence
of women in policing uh tangible steps
and measures have already been taken
after legislating in the police crime
sentencing and courts act to address
concerns surrounding data extraction
from victims devices during
investigations we are well on the way to
ensuring that victims are not without a
phone for more than 24 hours that's been
a a real deterrent to women coming
forward with complaints about rape or
serious sexual offenses we've LED with
the groundbreaking operations ceteria
program radical transformation on the
way the police investigate rape and
serious sexual offenses we're also
protecting the well-being of victims
During trials by offering pre-recorded
evidence for rape victims those are just
a few of the measures that we are taking
to send the message to women and girls
come forward if you are a victim and if
you do the police will be there to
support you Lawrence
thank you Mr deputy because the Home
Secretary just mentioned that she wants
women and girls to come forward with
those issues and allegations of rape the
charge rate for rape is 1.5 percent this
means that the vast majority of those
cases will never go to court let alone
secure a conviction this is not working
for women and girls the courage that
they have in coming forward than to know
that it will never secure that it's a
slap in the face yet again for those
women and girls what real action is the
Home Secretary going to change to
reverse this
well I've been working with
cross-government colleagues for uh
several years now in my former capacity
as the Attorney General on matters like
operation ceteria and operations ceteria
is groundbreaking and it is producing
real change in the way victims of rape
and serious sexual offenses are
experiencing the criminal justice system
we are seeing an increase in referrals
by the police to the crown prosecution
service that is a sign of progress we
are seeing an increase in the rate of
charge by the crown prosecution passing
the case on to the court service and we
will see an improvement in the number of
convictions that we secure I agree there
is a lot to do but progress has been
made
Laura Faris
the first allegation of serious sexual
assault was made against David Carrick
in 2003 and over the course of the next
18 years there were eight or nine
allegations of rape and through all of
that he was not suspended from work in
fact during that period he was actually
promoted within the force
what is common to all of these cases is
that there appears to be some kind of
omerta or closing of ranks between
senior Personnel when a criminal
allegation is made against one of their
brethren does my right honorable friend
agreed that the time has come to
Outsource the disciplinary
decision-making decision to another
either another force or at the very
least an officer who does not know the
policeman who is the subject matter of
this kind of allegation
honorable friends write to point to the
failings uh In Sum the Metropolitan
Police should have carried out a re-vet
of David Carrick in 2011. this wasn't
done until 2017.
and the Metropolitan Police acknowledge
that this would not have necessarily
changed the vetting outcome so those
systemic problems are prevalent and
that's why we need to take action to fix
them at Smith
s
we're back again Home Secretary like I'm
just exhausted about the number of times
in this house we have to talk about this
issue because women in Lancashire have
seen what's happened what's been in the
newspapers about David Carrick and they
saw about Wayne cousins and they've seen
about so many of the cases Home
Secretary
and they they want to know where there
is no legal requirement for vetting when
officers move between forces so yes
we're talking about the met today but we
could equally be talking about
Lancashire constabulary so Home
Secretary
I'd like to know what plans are in place
to legally require vetting when officers
move between forces to stop these
perpetrators moving around the country
to avoid Justice
where we need to ensure that there's the
right system in place to actually
properly identify inappropriate
candidates what we've seen thus far is
that actually there are inappropriate
processes so that people who are not
right for policing are falling through
the gaps falling through the net that
needs to change that's why I'm glad that
the Met commissioner has actually
already committed to instilling an
anti-corruption and abuse command unit
to properly look at how people are who
are inappropriately getting into the
police force and we will take further
action to look at the disciplinary
process and the the reports which are
currently running their course need to
conclude so we have an Evidence base to
take the appropriate action in
legislation if necessary civilians
and utterly shameful and appalling case
I've I've seldom seen such a palpable
sense of shock in this chamber as we've
witnessed today
and in responding to these terrible
crimes I hope the homosexury will also
look at the Benjamin hannam case of a
few years back where it is deeply
worrying that someone who had been a
member of a banned extremist group
National Action managed to be recruited
as a probationary police officer
well I think all cases are
um abhorrent and uh where where
confidence and policing is shattered and
uh you know the the the reputation uh of
the force is undermined that's why we
want to ensure that Chief constables
take the recommended action which has
been set out uh comprehensively
increasing the minimum standards for
pre-employment checks establishing
better processes for managing risks
relating to vetting decisions and
ensuring that the quality and
consistency of their vetting decision
making is improved Brian Smith thank you
Mr Deputy speaker I undertook the police
and parliamentary scheme with both the
Metropolitan Police and Avon and
Somerset going into the homes and
situations of the country's most
vulnerable people overwhelmingly women
that those women can't be confident
about those police officers is an
abhorrent situation but we've heard
nothing from the Home Secretary about
what she's going to do to finally
introduce mandatory National views on
vetting people in Bristol particularly
women in Bristol want to know that all
those police officers are being vetted
appropriately that that applies across
the country will she now commit to that
being operationalized
well the government legislated in
February of 2020 to strengthen the
police complaints and discipline systems
making them more transparent more
proportionate and more accountable this
included new powers for the independent
office the iopc including the power of
initiative ensuring that the iopc can
commence investigations without
requiring a referral from the police as
well as measures to stream streamline
and speed up decision making those build
on previous reforms and as I announced
today we'll carry out a more in-depth
review Into the disciplinary process and
if legislation is needed to change then
we will do that the polar bone utterly
shameful and shocking case the the vast
majority of police officers in the met
and across the country believe in and
perform to the highest Professional
Standards but they want to see their
fellow officers who do not have
appropriate action taken against them
but the problem is they just don't
believe that appropriate action will be
taken and chief constables are tearing
their hair out because they know they
have some officers who are not fit to be
in the police service but they can't
dismiss them easily so can I join the
calls from the right honorable lady the
member for camwell and Peckham for the
government to bring forward legislation
to revise the dismissal procedures for
police officers because the sooner we
get rid of police officers who are not
fit to serve the better it will be for
concern
I agree wholeheartedly with my right
honorable friend as baroness Casey
identified in her interim review at the
end of last year the misconduct process
takes too long offices and staff don't
have confidence in the process
allegations relating to sexual
misconduct other discriminatory Behavior
are less likely than other misconduct
allegations to result in a case to
answer decision there is a real need for
Action to take place that's why we're
going to come up with the proposals on
the back of the review that I've
announced today Helen Hayes thank you Mr
Deputy speaker when Sarah everard was
abducted from a street in London not far
from my constituency and brutally
murdered by a serving police officer
with a history of predatory behavior the
then Deputy Commissioner of the
Metropolitan Police said there was Zero
Tolerance of misogyny in the met the
appalling crimes of David Carrick show
that this was clearly not the case and
the current commissioner says that there
are between 800 thousand officers
currently under investigation for abuse
so can I ask the Home Secretary because
she hasn't answered this question so far
today what is she doing to ensure that
there are actually consequences and
accountability for the enablers in
police forces up and down the country
who protect abusers and allow them to
continue their activities under cover of
their warrant card because dealing with
that issue is an essential prerequisite
for zero tolerance to mean anything at
all
yeah
well the action that needs to be taken
has been set out incredibly widely and
comprehensively in several reports that
includes increasing the minimum
standards for pre-employment checks
establishing better processes for
assessing analyzing and managing the
risks relating to vetting decisions
corruption investigations and
information security improving the
quality and the consistency of decision
making when it comes to vetting and
extending the scope of the law relating
to the police complaint and misconduct
procedures there's a very clear plan of
action that is necessary amongst Chief
constables the College of policing and
the mppc and the home office is
monitoring and taking action where
necessary would you grab first Deputy
speaker today's debate shows the depth
of violence against women and girls even
by some of those in whom the public
should have the greatest trust and
therefore public confidence in policing
will be rattled the Home Secretary said
that David Carrick had been recruited
before Titan vetting rules were
introduced so will my right honorable
friend work with local police Chiefs to
find out how many people in their forces
are in their view potentially dangerous
to The Wider public so that they and we
can reassure our constituents as soon as
possible that there are no David
carricks lurking in gloucestershire or
elsewhere
well that is exactly why for the Met
they have carried the Met commissioner
has instituted a review of historic
cases where there may be a flag for a
domestic incident and they are
rigorously checking their data against
National databases I encourage all Chief
constables to take similar action to
ensure that similar cases can be rooted
out and action can be taken hello
Barefoot Mr Deputy speaker the problems
that Mark Rowley faces in the
metropolitan police run very deep indeed
I've been supporting a constituent of
mine with her allegations of threatening
and controlling Behavior against a
senior police officer and in the two
years that I've been supporting her the
police have completely failed to
investigate the case properly they've
failed to consider the impact on the
children failed to interview Witnesses
failed to get Essential Medical Records
and these are senior officers that are
standing in the way of this
investigation as was the case with Wayne
cousins as was the case with David
Carrick so Mark Rowley is making
specific request to assist him in making
the changes that he needs to make in the
metropolitan police we cannot wait for
another review so will she commit to
sitting down with Mark Rowley and give
him the resources and the support that
he needs now yeah very good
may I just uh clarify one point that I
referred to earlier when it comes to
some of the findings of uh baroness
Casey I just want to be clear that the
allegations that she found relating to
sexual misconduct and other
discriminatory behaviors are less likely
than other misconduct allegations to
result in a case to answer decision I
think I might have said the the opposite
before but what I say I agree that's why
I've built a very strong relationship
with Sir Mark rally I spoke to him
yesterday I have been speaking to him
regularly about exactly what action we
are taking both from a parliamentary and
legislative point of view but also from
an operational perspective on the ground
yeah there's an appalling case and a
very another very dark day for the
Metropolitan Police for our trust in
them and particularly for women's trust
in them it's not the first and I fear it
won't be the last why I applaud what the
government is doing in terms of better
prosecution of rape and support for
victims those are after the fact we need
to work on prevention and prevention
comes through culture as many others
have said does she agree that there are
two aspects of that culture there's the
Casual day-to-day misogyny that we see
from the nicknames that some of their
fellow officers not all had for them
themselves but there's also the
institutional misogyny and denial that
came from the multiple reports that were
made to the Metropolitan Police the
opportunities for vetting they were all
missed and resulted in many many more
rapes and will she work with a
commissioner of the Metropolitan Police
to address both these aspects of the
culture
my little friend's absolutely right that
I must say that the vast majority of
police officers uphold the higher
standards of behavior and
professionalism but there are pockets of
culture whereby standards fall short we
need to root that out and first thing to
do is to identify exactly what form it
takes the extent to which it is
prevalent and then we will know the
steps that we can legitimately take to
stop it happening again Mr Cooper thank
you Mr Deputy speaker David Carrick was
a metropolitan police officer but many
of his crimes were perpetrated in
Hertfordshire
uh where they many of them would have
been reported
as a Hertfordshire NP I would like to
pay tribute to the bravery and
perseverance of the rape survivors but
could I ask the secretary of state will
the actions or inaction of Hertfordshire
police be looked at as part of any
review and could I push her again as
many other colleagues have done to
confirm that she will introduce vetting
of officers when they transfer between
forces and will she also look at
Outsourcing disciplinary actions
well there is obviously going to be uh
the Carrick case will be uh looked at by
Lady Angelini and hopefully those issues
that she refers to will be fleshed out
but I am also interested in the point
that she raises about transfer of police
officers it's been identified for
insufficient vetting is taking place
when police officers are moving between
forces we need to take the action to
improve that
Lloyd Russell Moyle thank you Mr Speaker
this is another case and a long list of
cases and it's not just a misogyny it's
on race and it's on homophobia yeah and
we know that when Sadiq Khan called in
the commissioner and asked her the then
commissioner to produce a report about
what she was going to do rather than
doing her work she walked out the door
and had the backing of this government
rather than backing Sadiq Khan so now we
know that this is a systemic problem in
the metropolitan police and probably
police around the country is it time
that we move disciplinary matters away
from the police force concerned and
allow women and other victims to be able
to report to an independent service when
it's regarding a police officer without
fear or favor that it will be covered up
well I think what is important is that
we ensure that whatever disciplinary
process is in places that actually works
it's clear that there are serious
questions about its efficacy the time it
takes the process heavy uh uh experience
and ultimately that bureaucracy and
procedure are prevailing over ethics and
Common Sense we need to ensure that the
system is fit for purpose and that
police officers who are falling short in
their behavior are dismissed
thank you Mr Speaker and this is a
policing issue but it's not just a
matter for policing it's also a societal
issue and how we deal with Predators who
are determined and devious and it's a
fundamental issue about safeguarding and
the professional misjudgments that are
made that allow this
um Behavior to go unreported will the
Home Secretary raise the issue of
safeguarding and its need to cut across
all policy areas to ensure that
vulnerable people are protected with our
cabinet colleagues
well we have a designated Minister for
safeguarding she sits alongside me here
and so definitely in the home office we
prioritize the welfare of women and
girls and victims of crime more
generally there's a huge project of work
ongoing uh important relationship with
stakeholders and it's important that
confidence amongst victims and those who
are directly affected by these heinous
crimes are supported in the maximum
possible way by the criminal justice
system
can I thank very much the Home Secretary
for uh outlining our plan of action uh
to respond in a positive and strong way
uh trust in the police is an essential
component of the justice system and why
is it's clear that trust has been broken
uh and we kind of forget that this uh
that there is an overming number of
decent and solid policemen or police
women in our forces across the United
Kingdom
rebuilding trust in the in the screening
process may take some work so how does
the the Home Secretary intend to ensure
that all local forces Implement Lessons
Learned in the math to restore
confidence because conference is stored
is what we need thank you
Home Secretary The Honorable gentleman's
absolutely right and there is a a large
amount of work now not only for the met
but also the wider policing family to
restore and rebuild trust and confidence
amongst the general public but also uh
women and girls I visited some uh local
forces Kent Police I visited before
Christmas and actually there are some
there's there is a very good example of
how the force is really leading from the
front instituting a whole raft of
operational measures to support uh
victims of serious sexual offenses and
rape and rebuilding trust with local
communities so it is possible and I'm
very heartened by the progress that I'm
seeing around the country that completes
the statements those who wish to leave
please do so
right we come to the next statement I
call the Secretary of State for Scotland
Alistair Jack
because
today
I will make an order under Section 35 of
the Scotland act 1998 preventing the
gender recognition reforms Scotland bill
from proceeding to Royal ascent
this order will mean the presiding
office of the Scottish Parliament will
not submit the bill for Royal Ascent
this government believes however that
transgender people deserve our respect
our support and our understanding
my decision is centered on the
legislation's consequences for the
operation of Reserve matters including
equality legislation across Scotland
England and Wales
the Scottish government's bill would
introduce a new process for applying for
legal gender recognition Scotland the
changes include reducing the minimum age
a person can apply for a gender
recognition certificate from 18 to 16
and removing the need for a medical
diagnosis and evidence of having lived
for two years in the required gender
the bill would amend the gender
recognition act 2004 which legislated
for a single gender recognition system
across the United Kingdom and which
received a legislative consent motion
from the Scottish Parliament
the approach taken in the Scottish
government's gender recognition Reform
Bill was the subject of intense debate
in the Scott